hey what's going on everybody i'm dave
rubin this is the reuben report
direct message and today is june 28 2021
and i'm feeling good today i celebrated
my
45th birthday on saturday that's right
45
years young people we had a big party
here about a hundred people
in los angeles no masks
drinking eating more drinking
more eating and a lot more drinking
maybe some other stuff
it was a great weekend i just really i
just had a great weekend and i hope you
had a great weekend too
and i'm feeling just very appreciative
about life
and the world and the state of things
and
so i just wanted to start this show with
a thank you to you guys
uh to any of you that view this show
that listen to this show that support me
in any way
of course a special shout out to any of
you guys uh that support and are members
of reubenreport.locals.com that's
that's sort of the core base of people
that allow me to do the things
that i want to do in life and and build
the things that i want to build whether
it's this show
or locals or just a good decent life
that i can celebrate
and uh and i'm feeling just well that's
just a heartfelt thank you to you guys
and i i realized this weekend as i had
friends and family around and i had
a lot a lot of people that you guys
would know from the show but also
family and cousins and nieces and
nephews and
old friends and new friends and all
kinds of stuff that really at 45
at this moment at 45 knock on well my
desk not wood but
i got a marble desk here knock on marble
um
i'm feeling pretty good about about life
like i get we're in the midst of this
odd revolution
and things are weird on the outside in
many ways but but
personally in terms of the work that i
do and the life that i have at the
moment and and
physically and mentally like i fear i
feel clear
and good and uh and i hope that i'm able
to
you know transmit a little of that a
little of that to you guys so
uh one thing that i wanted to do just
real quick before we start the show
today
is uh we gave away t-shirts at the show
we had uh we as i said we had about 100
people here we ordered about 125 shirts
or so
so we've got about 20 shirts left over
so what i want to do is
if you want the official dave rubin
birthday shirt yes i love dave rubin
people put them on
at the end if you want the official
shirt we've got about 20 of them left so
the next
20 people that sign up for an annual
membership only if you sign up for
annual and this is for new signups only
not if you remember currently
sorry otherwise things get very
complicated if you are a new member and
you sign up right now the first
20 people that do that will get the
remaining shirts all you got to do is
sign up at reubenreport.locals.com for
an
annual membership and then uh forward
that sign up email that you'll get once
you sign up just forward that to
support locals.com with your shipping
address real quick
sign up annually you'll get the email
from us saying
you signed up you just forward that to
support locals.com
with your shipping address and you will
get the official
i love dave rubin shirt there's only
about 125 of them i think exactly 125 of
them
uh in circulation and you will have one
oh and by the way because of our
interview with
president trump on friday we had the
biggest three-day growth
in the community that we've ever had
those of you of course who watched the
show
on youtube on friday noted we had to
edit out 22 seconds
three different little snippets 22
seconds total of things that the
president
said that we were told by our youtube
contact that if you air this we don't
know what's going to happen now i can't
just risk my channel being blown up
so we put sound bars over it on youtube
we did put the full thing on locals i've
been preparing
for this censorship nonsense forever
that's why i started the company
and because of that we had literally our
biggest three-day growth since since i
started locals basically since we
launched
the community obviously right at the
beginning it was a massive jump um so
welcome to all the new community members
and just one other thing on on the trump
interview and then we'll get to the show
uh is that i i just gotta tell you i
freaking loved interviewing that guy
we're gonna work on doing something in
person but more than anything else i
really did
you know i always tell you guys i i'm
very active in the locals community in
terms of responding to people and
reading comments and all of that kind of
stuff
but you know i can't be in youtube
comments really like it's just too messy
and it's just too time consuming like i
just don't have the time beyond anything
else
but i really wanted to sort of like just
take a temperature
of what people thought because it's been
a while since people heard from trump
the comments were unbelievable i mean
you know i think a lot of you thought
that i asked him the right questions and
humanized him the right way and that he
was funny and refreshing
but more than anything else people were
like boy the level of honesty
that he puts out there is so in contrast
to what we're
bludgeoned with with biden and pasaki
and everything else not to say trump is
the endless truth teller
of all time and he even kind of hinted
that at one point he's like we're
politicians like it is what it is
but i think his his basic message in
that interview
of if you believe in america and you
don't want open borders and you don't
want critical race theory
in the schools and you want some
semblance of this thing that we
we've all grown to love for so many
years uh then then we're in a lot of
trouble right now
so he did a rally this weekend and uh
hopefully just
we don't have to make it about trump but
the idea of
someone that will fight for good decent
people
and and inspire people to stand up for
themselves that's what we need more of
and i think partly
maybe that's why you guys support me
here and as i said i'm just i'm just
feeling
appreciative and truly you person
watching this on youtube
at this moment i i thank you and i
double thank the people watching this on
locals
uh where we do have live streaming by
the way and i've been talking to my guys
i think i want to start doing post game
shows
not every day but every now and again
after we do a show a little live stream
maybe just me on the camera just talking
about what went right on the show what
went wrong
did we make any mistakes do we have to
correct anything
i don't mind correcting myself you know
anything's possible all right guys let's
get to it we got three stories today
first off the w.h.o you know those guys
who say one thing next week say another
thing next week say another thing next
week say another thing another thing
another thing another thing
uh they got an update on masks we'll get
to that just a sec
then al gore you may remember this uh
charlatan he was the vice president
under uh bill clinton
big environmental guy even though he has
a huge house in tennessee that uh
they've done stories on like he racks up
these crazy elec electric bills he flies
all over the world
in a private jet but he's always you
know telling you what to do with your
life
well now he's like talk about trump this
guy is now as fake tanned as trump
and talking about how evil trump is and
all evil trump supporters are
uh so we're going to talk about that and
then just talking about ridiculous
people this
this stelter potato guy over on cnn uh
he's been watching fox news for all of
the bad
things that they're doing on fox news
especially on that scary sean hannity
show
and uh he he basically laid it out on
his ridiculously named show reliable
sources which of course as you know
should be called unreliable sources
he laid it out yesterday and basically
everything he attacks hannity for is
true
and all of the things he says are false
it's like irony is dead people
so we've got a lot to talk about here we
go let's start with this vaccination
situation
we've got a quote here from the new york
post
as the highly contagious delta variant
of the coronavirus gained traction
around the world
the world health organization urged
vaccinated people
to continue to wear masks and social
distance according to reports
vaccine alone won't stop community
transmission
dr marie angela simmo the who's
assistant director general for access to
medicines and health products said
during a briefing
in geneva according to cnbc people need
to continue to use masks consistently
being ventilated spaces hand hygiene
the physical distance avoid crowding
this still continues to be extremely
important
even if you're vaccinated when you have
a community transmission
ongoing now i'm going to get to uh an
update on the specifics about what the
vaccine does related to this
variant in just a sec but the reason i
wanted to cover this story was because
just in the last week or two
in most of the country we're pretty much
open right you can pretty much
go where you want to go if you want to
wear a mask wear mask if you don't want
to wear a mask
don't wear a mask if you want a socially
distant socially distance if you want to
stay
locked in a basement in a dark room and
have someone feed you fish heads once a
week you could do that too it's kind of
we're getting back to that
choice thing that you make decisions
over your life
thing um but now the who is saying
there's this delta variant now i'm not
going to sit here and tell you that i
know exactly what's going on
with the delta variant and i believe it
probably exists
and i believe that we will find out more
about it and figure out how to take
precautions related to it but at some
point
and i would argue that point was
probably about a year ago if not more at
this point
at some point you got to just go ahead
and live your life and make those
decisions right for yourself and i don't
know
who what kind of sane person would be
sitting at their house
reading these articles waiting for
information from the who or the cdc or
anything else
and then taking that information and
deciding as if that's gospel and that's
what they must do the same people who
told us not to wear masks and then wear
a mess
and then we read the fouchy emails where
he told a friend who was going on
vacation like a year ago that masks that
you buy in stores
don't really work and we know i mean you
all know this i was on a plane
coming back from miami last week the
people that are well you have to wear a
plane on the uh
you have to wear a mask on the planes
and the people that have the mask on you
can see the masks are open
at different ends you got people with
beards that are inconsistent in them
you know it's got an opening here and a
crack over here and a crevice over here
and all that stuff
and you know it's like i'm not saying
ignore these people but i'm saying you
gotta at least take it
with a grain of salt but now let's get
to some info on this this is from
medical news today they said that the
researchers found that antibodies from
vaccinated individuals were not as
effective
as neutralizing the virus variant in a
lab study
but despite this they write that the
vaccine's not neutralization potential
is well established
so anyway there's a little bit of
conflicting information here on one hand
they don't seem to have enough
information as to whether
the vaccines do anything related to this
delta variant and on the other hand it
seems like perhaps
they do and that there's at least
potential right neutralization
potential that's the phrase that they
used so the question is
is this fear-mongering at this point
will we ever be able to move forward and
look
i was i was at the supermarket this
weekend
and it's 50 50 here here in la and i get
it's wacky la
5050 wearing a mask not wearing a mask
and people aren't just dropping dead oh
and if you want to hear just a freaking
amazing like
talk about like you know when life comes
together and you just get a sign
from god that things are working in life
so i've told you guys and people have
asked me in the q and a's about
what music i listen to this is a little
sidebar from the story but i think
you'll see why i'm bringing it up
uh so i love love love frankie valli in
the four
seasons 60s music and and really you
know oh what a night and
and grease and you know who loves your
baby like just i just love that stuff
anyway
we were trying to get frankie's in his
80s we were trying to get him to come to
my house
to to sing it turns out we don't live
that far from each other we have a
couple
couple strange connections and uh and it
was gonna be just a
crazy amount of money and he's he's in
his eighties as i said and like all
right that's fine so it was gonna be a
ton of money but we were just gonna try
to do it just to see if we could make it
happen for a couple grand basically it
didn't work out
but then on saturday i go to pick up
some grapefruit juice for the party
and frankie valley is at the supermarket
thumping a watermelon
and i thought that's all i needed that's
all i needed i bring this all up because
he was wearing a mask and
again you can make a choice i didn't
judge him for it he's of a certain age
and all of that stuff the point is make
some decisions in your life that work
for you and i think everything will be
okay
let's talk about al gore who was the vp
under bill clinton he of course lost the
uh 2000
election to was that the 2000 election
yeah the 2000 election
to george w bush that was the florida
hanging chad
election where it went all the way up to
the supreme court well al gore
basically since he has been vice
president has done a bunch
of business things all sort of related
to the environment and most of them kind
of fail but he makes
a lot of money on them i'll get to some
of that in just a sec but just this
weekend
he showed up and he's trying to freak
people out on trump
and i will only color this to say look
at the tone of his skin for a guy who
doesn't like
trump very much he's going with the
trump bronze take a look
i would say please do the right thing
acknowledge reality
stop hurting this country stop
undermining
democracy honor the great and honorable
traditions of the united states of
america
this cannot go on the way it is now i
will
i will point out pamela that it's kind
of a sideshow
and people are turning off to it now i
really think they're beginning to
and joe biden's popularity continues to
rise
look at what he's done in controlling
the pandemic
look at what he's done in facilitating
the incredible
economic resurgence with a very strong
climate plan going overseas and really
bringing the respect for the united
states
back up again after it sunk to a
historic
low during the previous four years for
reasons we
all understand man al gore what a
ridiculous
charlatan what a snake oil salesman that
guy is
uh just to tell you one thing that al
gore did after becoming vice president
al gore created a tv station called
current tv now you've probably never
heard of it
but basically he used all of his
governmental connections
to create this tv station and the real
value of a tv station it was a
progressive
really far left news network right i did
one or two shows as a guest on the
network actually way back when i was i
was a crazy lefty it's
all true it's true all of it um anyway
he created this cable channel and he
used
basically it's very difficult to get a
cable channel right you can't just be
like call up time warner be like i want
a tv channel
you got to have connections to do it so
he used all of his connections
in government to get this left-wing
network on cable so you know it gets on
verizon and it gets on
time warner spectrum or whatever it may
be whatever your local cable chat is
anyway the channel existed
for a couple years it was an abject
failure
ratings failure lost a ton of money and
then what did al gore do
al gore then sold the channel
the worthless channel for 500 million
dollars
to the government of qatar he sold it to
al jazeera which is just the media wing
of the government
of qatar so by the way qatar can we
confirm this i believe it's the number
two
oil exporter on earth i think i'm right
about that we'll get the we'll get the
exact numbers on that in just a second
um glenn beck and the blaze tv actually
tried
to buy current tv now the thing is what
you're buying is not current tv meaning
the shows that are on current tv
or any of the talent that's on current
tv you just want the access right you
just want to be on the cable channels
and then you bring in all of your shows
you bring in all of your talent
all of your programming etc etc so al
gore
decided instead of selling his failed
channel
to glenn beck okay now obviously i love
glenn beck he doesn't have to sell it to
glenn beck he can do whatever he wants
as a private person
but he decided to sell it and make 500
million dollars
by selling it to the number two oil
exporter qatar
okay uh i can't get total confirmation
it's number two oil exporter but
we know that uh we they export a lot of
oil and al gore doesn't like oil right
it's a fossil fuel he's got a whole
issue with fossil fuels
so he's just the worst sort of charlatan
that there is he says a couple things in
there that are crazy so he's talking
about trump hurting democracy now again
these are the same people that for four
years
said that trump was a russian puppet and
hillary clinton saying the election was
illegitimate
and 24 hours a day for four years every
day
trying to destroy trump that's what they
were doing okay fine trump's undermining
he's hurting democracy he's undermining
democracy people are turning
turning off i don't know an awful lot of
people watched our interview although
youtube obviously
uh suppressed it because it only has a
couple hundred thousand views
the audio podcast did really well they
have trouble uh
suppressing audio podcasts more a little
more information on qatar thanks
they have the world's third largest
proven natural gas reserve and it's
and is the second largest exporter of
natural gas
i would like to know more on the fossil
fuel side but they export a ton of stuff
like
and either way qatar they've got some
human rights problems i think i think
you get the point okay
um so he he did al gore actually did the
producers did you ever see the play the
broadway play the producers
they create a flop they realize that
creating a flop
actually will make you more money than
creating something successful that's
exactly what he did
with uh with current tv uh what else
does he say there
uh he says biden's popularity is on the
rise
i have no idea what he's talking about
right like what are you talking about
actually
i don't know anyone that didn't like
biden before that likes him now the
people that didn't like him actually
think he's more incompetent
and has you know sort of worse scrambled
egg brains than they thought
before i think most people see that now
and i would say plenty of people
that did vote for him are kind of like
this ain't right so that was another one
then he said the economic resurgence
thanks to joe biden
have you guys seen the economic
resurgence no conor
nope these guys haven't seen it and they
have jobs okay
they haven't seen it um and then uh oh
and then that the people overseas this
is the lefties always love this one
the people overseas like us more the
foreigners like us more the europeans
like us more
did you guys see the g7 biden was
wandering around
wandering no you're not getting a bonus
nice try i see what you did there
uh biden was wandering around like an
old man at an old age home
shuffling his feet babbling on confused
there are moments where he's just
completely freaking lost but they like
us more
maybe you're right actually on that gore
because now they know we've got this
you know half-wit puppet up there that
they can do whatever they want so that's
another one
and then of course you know we've done
more on climate we've done more on
climate
you know okay fine we've done more on
climate like no you know he got us back
into the paris climate accords the paris
climate accords as we've talked about
were a non-binding agreement but this is
what lefties and progressives love
they love things that are just on a
piece of paper if you just do what i've
done throughout the show if you just
scribble things down
and you hand it to somebody they love
that oh you said something nice and you
put it on a piece of paper it must be a
thing
the paris climate accords which mostly
put the onus on america to do things and
pay into the system had no mechanism to
force any country
to do anything much less should do we
have any right
uh as americans to tell china and india
you know countries going through their
industrial revolutions do we have any
right to tell them what to do i thought
we're supposed to stay out of people's
business you know so anyway core is just
terrible and
and the fake tan thing the fake tan
thing can we put video back up for just
like
three like we get like five here's five
seconds about look at this fake tag man
i would say please do the right thing
acknowledge reality
stop hurting this country stop
undermining them
acknowledge reality you're white and
pasty man accept it
all right let's move on uh this brian
stelter guy you know
you know my feelings on this guys 50 50
whether we have to talk about these
people anymore or not it's totally 50
50. i i've discussed it with many people
do we just start ignoring these
ridiculous clowns who all the way by the
way i know that they watch this show
like i know that plenty of producers at
cnn and a bunch of the other
uh channels watch this show because i'm
not stupid and i have insiders that a
lot of these people and
and a lot of these places and a lot of
the people that work for you guys don't
like you guys
because you're all frauds and liars well
brian stelter he's got this show
reliable sources it should be unreliable
sources you know all that stuff
and all he does all day long is
basically
watch fox news to try to figure out a
way to take down
fox news that's what cable news has
reduced itself to
um so here's a video of brian stelter
yesterday
ironically accusing hannity fox
and the right wing scary people of
conspiracy
conspiracies and inflammatory language
take a look
to understand why so many republicans
have abandoned democracy
to see why so many believe the big lie
to get why so many are trying to rewrite
voting rules
you have to hear the poisonous
propaganda that the gop's activist base
is listening to
you have to really hear it it's coming
more from sean hannity than from trump
right now
so that's what we did this week we
watched every episode of sean hannity's
show
and we color-coded it as you can see we
focused on his language the insults and
phrases that he repeats every night
biden's a weak frail cognitive mess
sanity says
yet the democratic party is portrayed as
an existential threat
hannity calls it the new green deal
socialist party and he labels some dems
extremists he calls american cities hell
holes
sometimes he calls them democratic run
hellholes and he says the media is a mob
full of quote stalkers don't get numb to
this abusive language
because it is through these insults it
is through these attacks
that hannity wields power this dark dire
language
is fundamentally authoritarian hannity
is spouting
poison i literally just cracked up
throughout that even though i've seen it
like 10 times this morning
first off pretty much everything hannity
said is right they are democratic
hellholes right
they are everything everything he says
he said the republicans the base they're
trying to rewrite the voting rules well
of course
stelter never explains to you what it is
that these gop
bills are trying to do like you know
have people use ids
to vote as i talked about last week i
went mini golfing
and to actually get the small golf club
i had to show
an id and they actually held it for us
these are not
crazy things but i love that stelter had
his people watch
all of the show and they had color
coding
people are watching this and they are
being br like that's the reverse of the
truth
that man's job is to reverse the truth
so i guess it does make sense that his
show reliable sources
is named backwards and it should be
unreliable sources like it's just
absolutely extraordinary and also the
way he's seating it that it's somehow
it's somehow those right-wingers who
don't believe
are nonsense that are being violent and
hannity's using inflammatory language to
rile people up
and it's like no man it's your base
burning down cities it's your base
looting and destroying windows and yes
they are in democratic hell holes
it's not happening in republican cities
so the question is
as always and i'm i'm as i said i'm 50
50 on this and i would love more
feedback so maybe this will be the
discussion of the day
in uh in the locals community is do we
have to keep
talking about those people to expose
them like that man and acosta
and that ridiculous larping lunatic uh
chris cuomo
and everyone at cnn they are actors
pretending to be journalists that's what
they are i'm not
a journalist i'm a guy who sits here i
tell you what i think
you can call me what you want but i
don't pretend i'm anything
other than what i am okay i am what i am
and that's all that i am i'm pop by the
sailor man there you go guys okay we're
gonna have a little spinach after the
show today
but the point is these people they are
lying to all
of these people and then you wonder why
people are insane you wonder why karens
are screaming at people and people are
angry
and fighting with people and and wearing
masks until they're
until they're 90 and dead and it's just
like it's just like
get control of your life that's my
message dave rubin at 45
get control of your life find happiness
find friends find good people eat good
food
do what you like doing and don't listen
to brian stelter how much more do you
need people
guys reminder my full episode with
president trump is up on youtube
although we did have to do the sound
bars on some parts so if you want to
watch the full thing
reubenreport.locals.com and then we did
do something a little different
for the interview this week i
interviewed christian angermeier who
has a company called a thai life that
just went to ipo they're doing
incredible stuff
related to psychedelics and how they can
help
depression and he talks about life
extension and robots and all kind of
it's really like a different take on
politics there's there's a political
theme to it i would say
but it's just a different type of show
uh than than what i've done before i
think you'll really enjoy it
and uh and as i said we now have live
streaming uh
on local so i'm gonna do a little more
live streaming post game shows that kind
of stuff over there
and uh lots of good stuff happening so
anyway i hope your monday is going well
hope you have a great week
let's do it again tomorrow see ya